there's a new attraction for thousands
of people enjoying the long holiday
weekend in North Carolina's Outer Banks
Shelly island is a destination that you
won't find on a standard map the giant
barrier island suddenly formed in the
Atlantic almost overnight
mark Strassmann is in Cape Hatteras
North Carolina on America's newest beach
mark good morning good morning I want to
show you something you see those cars
about a hundred yards away that's the
tip of the Outer Banks with all of their
famous beaches I'm walking on new Beach
on a new island that hundreds of people
are going to spend at least part of
their fourth of July weekend at here it
is one mile long a football field wide
and growing proof that whoever said no
one was building anymore beachfront
property was wrong pilot Larry Ely this
dip they got bigger it's deafening
higher built up we set up by kayak with
Danny couch to explore North Carolina's
newest barrier island
he's a ninth generation North Carolinian
a County Commissioner here and a
lifelong resident of the Outer Banks
couch has seen barrier islands pop up
before but not like this one he first
noticed back in April this is the mother
of all sandbars all of a sudden right
here where we're sitting what makes it
the mother of all sandbox it's a horse
it's huge it is big this area off North
Carolina's coast is one of the most
dynamic ocean environments on earth
nicknamed the graveyard of the Atlantic
with more than 2,000 documented
shipwrecks since 1585 two powerful
currents collide here the Gulf Stream
from the Caribbean flowing quickly north
and the Labrador Current from the Arctic
pushing south the currents collide
churning surf and sand at diamond shoals
a cluster of shifting underwater
sandbars off the coast of Cape Hatteras
satellite imagery from last March on
show once this large shoal surfaced it
is just kept growing and the two
currents pushed all this sand together
and suddenly here we are
yes sir and sustain these shoals to know
buddy will never be able to predict
what's going to come out of the ocean
for what it's going to look like over
Memorial Day
eleven-year-old Caleb Regan visited for
the first time he noticed shells
scattered everywhere and gave the place
a name that stuck
Shelly Island I thought it would just be
like a little family nickname that and I
can't believe it had gotten this big
very incredible tourists kept coming to
Shelly island both for the shells and
the novelty Ella Adams did for me it's
all new I'm originally from the
Netherlands do they have Islands but
from the air we also spotted potential
trouble sharks swimming near boaters and
waders Shelly island is so new no
federal or state agency regularly
patrols here so who owns us right now
nobody's really claiming ownership it's
sort of a no-man's land this could be
yours or mine or somebody's absolutely
we should be so lucky but it belongs to
the American people it's a phenomenon
enjoy it enjoy while we have it now
before you rush here to build your beach
house remember something nature gives
and nature can also take away the next
major hurricane that comes along could
blast this island as big as it is right
back into the Atlantic
Jeff mark the only thing but in the lack
of shoes or I'm not sure even that
flip-flops or not but is was the the
beach chairs for the interview used I'm
not sure whose idea it was but
tremendous all I needed was the cigar I
would've said a tropical drink instead
of the cigar but either way about the
surfing the surfing is supposed to be
pretty good down there ya know it's
great off North Carolina Bentley uh-huh
I do not know Jeff Glor was a surfer I'm
not I'm not a surfer I tried